in my sophomore year i walked onto the
crew team and it completely changed my
life
having that outlet for
stress
helps me enjoy both parts of my life
both the athletic and the academic side
a lot more
[Music]
we really just have an amazing team
culture i learn a lot from the people
that i'm around they definitely inspire
me to like be better on the water and
academically
[Music]
of the undergrad residences are within
like a five or so minute walk from the
boathouse we're at the boathouse now and
that's an undergrad dorm
[Music]
we kind of all push each other to become
the fastest boats that we can be but at
the same time in order to become the
best versions of ourselves we have to be
supportive of each other throughout the
way
[Music]
the entire crew just rowing is one
person you're all
moving at the exact same time the oars
are clicking in exactly the same rhythm
the boat is
surging through the water at the tempo
that you set
[Music]
that is just such an incredibly magical
moment that i've never experienced
anywhere
else we're division one and the spring
will definitely be roaring against a
bunch like the ivys in dartmouth
georgetown we have some races like out
in san diego
[Music]
the charles is definitely a very
historic river in the running community
head of the charles is one of the most
well-known regattas in the world going
through all the bridges and hearing
about all the turns that i've heard
about for so long and then just like
rowing that every single day it's like
it never gets old
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm sort of driven by like the
competitive aspect of it i just love
like racing
in the fall we do sort of like the
big like name brain races like the head
of the charles we go up to the head of
the fish in new york
being like
completely gassed and just dead after
the finish line but then you see the
other boat like you know two or three
seats back it's a great feeling
you're erging for the whole winter
season and then the payoff is that
moment when
you sprint in the last 200 meters pass
another boat by like a hair
and you know you get the medals you get
the trophy
you